my big thing is that I genuinely don't
think most things matter and so and so
I'm very big on lack of ego is why I'm
good at delegating
I actually think way too many people
suck at delegating because they're
egotistical and they don't deploy enough
humility and they actually are
micromanaging out of their own
insecurities and so I it's very easy for
me to delegate because because I trust
people and I trust them up front you
know my dad oh he says you've got to
earn my trust and I always say I'm
giving you trust and you've got to lose
it and actually it's kind of hard to
lose I think that's allowed me to go
fast it's allowed me to scale I think
it's a differentiator and I don't think
anything can really [ __ ] me and so I
give them the room I think delegation
has a lot to do with ego and and
insecurities and I watch and I'm able to
do a lot of things by giving people room
and and to me if I'm doing 97 things and
97 people are helping me and they're all
ranging from if a 10 was perfect
execution from a four point two to a
nine point seven doing 97 things from a
four point two to nine point seven is a
hell of a lot better than doing one or
two things at a 10 point oh the net
score game that's how I'm wired and
that's how I strategize and then I and
then as people prove that they could do
9.2 8.7 work I move them up and if they
prove they can do 11 point o work I
remind them that they maybe should be
doing it something up for themselves so
that's that's the bottom line
[Music]
the garage the firing of the youth
narada and stoner one apologetic